Welcome everybody to another business Q&A while we play League of Legends
answer your entrepreneurial questions. We're already getting up into the champ
select which is exciting. I am support Jrize's ADC and we're gonna try to get
some more Timo Himer. We lost the last game so we got to start a new streak so
we'll see how that goes. I'm hearing you through the phone there Rishi. There we
go. And I've got my usual co-host RishiCupTV. Welcome back Rishi. Hey Evan. Hello
everybody. Happy Fri-yay. It's Fri-yay in the house. It's Friday. I have a love-hate
relationship with Friday. I knew you would. Tell us about it. Well I just love
my work. I know. It's like it's the end of like I need to fight for work time on the
weekend as well as fight for everything else I didn't do on the weekend. So I
like being able to have my entire day of work. I love my work. So anyway we've got Jrize
in the house. J what's up? Yo yo. So we're gonna get into our game soon. Rishi what's
in the cup today? I've got some. I've got my regular Spanish coffee but I should
tell you all that I am trying coconut sugar today and it's okay. It's just it
looks like I've put sticks in my coffee. That's a little disturbing. But is the
coconut sugar more like less calories so you can do two cups of coffee a day? Is
this part of the experiment? I don't think so Evan. Honestly all these
different kinds of sugar there's still sugar at the end of the day. What if you put
half of the sugar? Like you can't do half? Half the sugar? No I can Evan. I just you
know. I do sometimes. I do sometimes and if it's a very high-end cup of coffee I
can do that because the quality of the coffee is so good it makes up for the
lack of sweetener. So it's just about increasing standards. Oh boy.
I like it. Could that be my metaphoric cup of higher standards? All I'm saying is coffee you
know. You can take it however you want to take it I'm just saying with coffee. Yes yes I
understand. All right well well what's the cup of like what's our message of
the day? My message of the day Evan is actually a mean quote. Okay. I love it.
It's Friday we're getting ready for the weekend even though Evan is not but my
quote is I love sleep. Cup of I love sleep because it's like a time machine
to breakfast. Oh wow okay good. I like that. Who said that? I don't know. Oh okay
random anonymous. It's a meme. All right I like it. Well I've got a whole bunch of
stuff in front of me. Let me let me quickly share everything I have in front
of me because it's kind of nuts. You don't see it on streams I gotta bring it
in. I have my peach tea, peach tranquility tea that J.R.I.E.S. brought me which I
love from Starbucks. I have my green smoothie that I need to drink that Nina
made that's good. I have my big cup of water. I have my protein thing I need to
drink and then a big cup of nettle tea with J.R.I.E.S. also got me and some
organic honey is in there and then we're short on lentils today so my
breakfast consists of there we go two hard-boiled eggs the other stream celery
with peanuts peanut butter and then a bunch of almonds and this is an almond
walnut mix but I don't like walnuts so I don't know what I'm gonna do with that
and almond so it's like it's chaos here it's all it's all stuff that I need to
consume so I'm excited. So we're in game already this is crazy here we need to
get to our first question we're in game I am team of support J.R.I.E.S. is
Heimer ADC so our experiment continues and we'll see how we do why don't we hit
up what's our first question let's do it all right and Evan you definitely should
have a video just for your breakfast routine because that's pretty intense
all of those cups and and things near your computer so that would be a cool
video it's not usually that intense on the food side it's usually just a bowl
of lentils but with the lentils being missing it's become a little crazier
today so yeah oh we should just shout out the chat before we get to our first
question absolutely you want to do it or shall I I can't see right now I'm
playing so oh we've got rise online in the house and also playing at your house
and we've got they know we've got Jen so much the Mazda and it looks like
that's everyone happy you guys are here thanks for thanks for joining us okay so
our first question today comes from Jay Smith and Jay Smith is making a comment
from a video that was called stolen ideas how to prevent big companies from
stealing your ideas okay and he says what if it's a cosmetic brand so yeah
it's an interesting question I actually didn't I'm not familiar with this
particular video I'd have to go back and watch it but I I'm wondering why Jay
feels like a cosmetic brand would be unique from another business in terms of
being ideas being stolen I would imagine that the same principles would apply
Evan do you have any thoughts on that one
cosmetics and why that was the only part of the question what if it's a
cosmetic spray yeah what if it's a cosmetic brand in regards to preventing
big companies from stealing your ideas yeah it doesn't doesn't really make a
difference most of the stuff on the channel doesn't really make a huge
difference to be honest you know like yeah you should be able to find even in
watching the top 10 videos or any of those success stories just because
you're not a singer it doesn't mean you can't learn from a successful singer the
lessons are still applicable at least the ones that I share it's not talking
about how to hit a certain note but all the lessons that we share you can learn
from but for yes stolen ideas if you if you'd have it protected right if you
had the patent for it great if you don't then people are gonna try to find a way
around it like when you're dealing with a big company they want to if you come
to them with an idea what they want to do is not pay you for it that's what a
big company wants to do they don't want to have to pay you for it so they're
gonna look for a way to do it themselves they're gonna look a look for a way
around whatever into look for intellectual property you have and find
a way to just do it themselves now if they can't because you have the patent
you have the right protection then then you're fine you know then they have to
find a way to work with you a lot of times that people won't release the
exact formula like coca-cola never releases their formula they don't have a
patent on on the formula for coca-cola because the patent runs out and you have
to when you make a patent you have to release exactly how you've done it so a
lot of a lot of those kinds of things like if you look at a you know Cheerios
or any of those mixes they won't they won't have a patent on it but they also
don't say exactly how that recipe is created so that's what I would be
looking at I don't think you have a like if somebody steals your idea that you're
the only thing you can do is sue them and you may not want us to go out and sue a
huge company we got Olaf here Jay yeah so whether it's cosmetics or whether
it's or whether it's anything else but you're like mixing and matching
ingredients together the same all the same rules apply
great looks like we're in the game team is winning barely happening two to one
where we have a we have a hard lane that I feel like should they should be doing
better than us but they're not right they should be destroying us just in
terms of the matchups oh I went way too far oh I'm gonna die I went way too far
I'm not gonna die Jay might die Jay don't die come back no Jay tried to save
me I went way too far was my bad it was my bad it's my bad oh Jay died it was my
bad my bad I know we were trash-talking how bad they were doing and then I made
a terrible play it was really bad it was I don't know what I was doing well yes
so team is now losing but confidence in our late game abilities let's see how we
do let's do it let's do it all right Monica says hi what is the ideal way to
find how other competitors are pricing okay all right Monica thank you for the
question um I my thoughts would just be I know a lot of the title if you want
more of the specific ins and outs of this but I mean a lot of the pricing
information for any company is is available on their website so definitely
if you haven't already started there I would I would start there you know I've
much more than that Evan yeah you know most pricing is I don't know what
industry she's in most pricing if you just research the industry you know I
think I think a lot of times though for most industries any pricing report is
gonna be outdated pretty quickly and maybe not the best use so just go to the
website or going to trade shows and seeing what's happening in the market I
think that's gonna be your best bet one thing I would think about is I want you
to be different I would be looking at whoa we're taking her ass not just
looking at you know not just not just getting on price but figuring out what's
special and unique and like having a having a price comparison to understand
where people are at is great and then understand that your value hopefully is
higher or you know it's a certain market it's gonna be higher just so that you're
not just doing the same things as everybody else I think I think it's
important but yeah just one or two shows looking at their websites even as you're
talking to potential customers have they thought about using somebody else to
solve this problem and you know who so you can go look them up you know when I
look at if I look at my so I have two businesses that I'm running it you know
pretty actively at the moment one is the salsa business which is which is a
competitive you know industry there's other people who have salsa classes I
compare myself more to the entertainment dollar there so I'll look at I care more
about what the price of a movie ticket is than what the price of my competitors
are because I understand that that's my real competition people who are taking a
salsa class really do you want to do something fun and different it's
entertainment more than anything else at the start so what a price of a movie
ticket is is a much better comparison for me and then the other one is like
my business and when I work with corporate clients I don't care at all
what other people in my industry are doing it's just really more function of
domain and supply where I have certain amounts of times to be able to do things
right like if I'm posting it if I'm working with a client I'll only do one
thing maximum per week and when that starts to get filled up I start charging
more so as my time fills up I start increasing my prices so two totally
different businesses but that's how I go about doing it and if you don't have
direct competitors then look at what people what is the closest like if there
was nobody else teaching salsa well there's people are still gonna go out
and want to watch a movie and they're still gonna want to go out and you know
do these other entertainment dollar things so that's oh you okay okay so
there's always there's always competition even there's no direct
competition it's where people spending those dollars and then looking at how
much those related activities are
and is it important to be asking this question like is is this where an
entrepreneur should start or do you think they should focus on I mean is it
the wrong foot to start out when you're just taking a lot of time to figure out
your competitors pricings and and whatnot or is that just kind of the wise
thing to do we got into a massive fight and Jay and I both died and I got a
kill like two for one there and I totally missed your question no that's
okay and I don't even I don't think it's actually a good question right now
because I think I'm answering it for myself but yeah we just had a big
conversation on Wednesday I think it was about you know dealing with the
competition and how the kind of the greater approach is thinking through you
know but I don't think it applies here because this is really about just some
of the practical pricing issues that I think every entrepreneur has to deal with
okay all right next question comes from Camille and Camille says hi Evan thank
you for this I believe I'm in a stage now where I believe I have a great idea
a lot of people also think it would work however I find it difficult to get
properly started and going I get really passionate in the thinking process I
enjoy the execution but whenever I get distracted I find it difficult to come
back to not sure if it's because of lack of discipline and since the passion
worth the comfort of my current full-time corporate job is telling me
stop trying so hard should I abandon the idea altogether and wait for something
I'll be persistent with or should I work on my habits and work ethic or should I
work on my habits and work ethic and force the idea into life all right I
like this question because I think it really is something that a lot of people
can relate to you have an idea but you don't get to it for whatever reason you
know you have another job or you don't feel like you're you know other things
come and distract you from getting to it in particular like with my channel one
of the things that I realized and this might apply is that like I had the idea
for what I'm doing on Rishi Cup TV I think like two three years before I even
started it and I just didn't really know how to start I YouTube was not on my
mind I actually was thinking about starting like a blog or something you
know and anyway there comes a time when it's never really convenient to do it
you just have to start and what you'll find too is that once you start the idea
kind of take the life of its own and what I mean by that is Rishi Cup TV was
good music good food good talk three years ago before I started YouTube by
the time I actually started on YouTube I'm realizing now the good music good
food good talk evolved and changed because when you start executing on your
idea things just kind of start to to transform I think it's the same with
Evan you know it was just entrepreneurs and now his ideas is transcending on
entrepreneurship so I think that you just need to start and and if you find
once you start that you don't like it enough you can always stop but if it
just stays in the idea stage of your head and mind it you know you'll never
know until you just start doing something
for me I agree I think a lot of people don't do it I think a lot of people do
hold themselves back can we get something this is true how did you get
over that shroom oh man that's crazy anyway I would really try to figure out
is it because you're not passionate about it or because you're you're you're
afraid of something you have a limiting belief when you really want to get through
what's that she says she gets really passionate in the thinking process right
but so the doing the execution right like is it is it that you are just you
know that you need a partner you need a business partner who can do some of
these things for you and you're just gonna focus on with new ideas like do
you have enough of the skills yourself to do it are you you know are you do
you want to do that like look at the other areas in your life have you gone
out and done stuff have you taken action or are you just always dreaming so it's
either it's either that you don't love the idea enough to go out and execute
against it or you're afraid and you're holding yourself back right like it's
easy to so for example if you if you really fear what other people think of
you but that's one of your limiting beliefs you really care what other
people think of you then come up with an idea is great it's fun you you're in
you're in your room by yourself at home a coffee shops whatever it's a solitary
exercise coming up with these ideas but then we have to go and do it now you're
gonna be on the public stage you're gonna be you know in front of people
there's a lot there's a lot more at stake now and because you're gonna be so
public maybe you don't do it maybe you hold yourself back now because it's
really your fear I got you I got you I got you these guys are not great man
don't trash-talk them don't trash-talk them we're gonna die again so having the
understanding and awareness to know what the reason is right and I don't know
just by yeah I don't know you so I can't I can't say oh we got cleaned up here
our team died so I gotta save that see what I can do here and what I try to
look at is this a consistent pattern for you like you start and stop and start
and stop and does it feel like you really love it and you really regret it
like I really wish that I did more and why aren't you so it's one of those two
things that maybe it maybe did the ideas wrong they're just not passionate enough
about it and maybe that you need to have somebody help you you know to round out
your your skill sets and what you're interested in doing or maybe just that
you're afraid and it's time to grow so a little more self self-analysis self
awareness to figure it out you'll be on your way yep great advice all right how's
everybody doing in the live chat we got a shout out to a blur camp and he's just
sharing some appreciation he says he loves listening to the stream while he's
at his job that's cool and yeah okay let's get to the next question
Andrew says when hiring that first person this was one of your videos Evan
about hiring so when hiring that first person did you look online for someone
to work for one hour per day or did you use someone locally for assistance
example Craigslist elance my biggest fear of hiring is not hiring anyone if
that makes sense thanks Evan hashtag believe nice definitely direct question
to you Evan but you're hiring process yeah the first guy I hired was somebody
local somebody that I knew I didn't know very well but I knew I needed help
with database work and he was a database guy and he was able to help me do some
of the work that I you know like I was doing super manually and he just knew
how to do it much better than I did so yeah the first guy was was oh oh nice
nice first guy was local but at the time too I wasn't aware of online options I
don't even know if you Lance and what was the other one at the time
freelancer.com or I don't know I don't know if those guys were even around or
if they did they didn't have a big place or and if they did I didn't even know
about them so I would have would have would I have gone online now I would
definitely go online I had a lot of the fears I think a lot of people have when
they hire like oh I can't see them in my office you know I don't know if
they're working hard all of that all of that stuff where I used to think like I
was always gonna have an office and people I was gonna work with me so yeah
so it means the short answer is yes I hired somebody local but if I was doing
it again now 2016 I would hire somebody online unless I knew the perfect person
locally but if I didn't have the connections I would do somebody I would
do it online.
Yeah I think two people would have a lot of fear around hiring remotely and you
seem to be type you know you seem like you've been able to do that so people do
you say to people yeah you know don't don't be too afraid to try the remote
hiring process? I you know I've done a couple videos on how the hiring process
I think is broken I think focus on the wrong things whether that's online or
offline by the way so yeah I think there's a lot of fears and there are
some you know legit fears too and also thinking about how you want to run a
company and what your vision is like I also thought I wanted to have an office
like I I envisioned a team where we're all working together and we show up
every day and the camaraderie and you know that was that was my vision when I
first started the business but then my team wanted to move away it sounds
really bad how I said it but just like they wanted to move away for like they
wanted to explore and travel and do other things but still work for me right
I was the old I was in my mid now my yeah mid 20s I guess mid 20s 19 yeah
like you have probably mid 20s when I started doing that stuff early the mid
20s and I was the oldest person my company everybody else was younger all
right we got tower you're gonna split I'll split now okay oh that's good that's
good dragon so I was the old I was the old guy in the business and everybody
kind of wanted to go off and do their own thing and see the world and you know
how how the kids are you know how the kids are these days them kids your
misfit kids how the kids are somehow it was a really tough decision like huh do
I let them continue to work for me or do I just go find somebody else and I love
like they were doing a good job they're doing good work and so I decided that I
would that I would I would let them keep doing it I would test it out as an
experiment and it was a combination of one the fear that the fear that like I
don't know what's gonna happen these guys are I can't control them anymore I
can't see and I think having had them in the office gave me more comfort like I
know these guys they're they're hard workers it's not some random person and
then to like my vision of what I wanted to do and this was kind of it seemed
like it was against it so yeah but I would I would if I were doing again I
would hire I would hire on up work I love up work yeah great yes good luck
and I have a great question in this in the chat actually from Damasta and
Damasta says Evan does Evan have any revelations thoughts on the
non-notification experiment this week does Evan have any feedback revelations
thoughts on the non-notification experiment this week so this is something
I've been testing I think it said it on the gratitude stream last yesterday
where I'm only experiencing sending one notification per day out to people and
also the most of the live streams happen on a separate channel as opposed to the
main channel and so far all the metrics have been positive subscribers are up
views are up I haven't looked at engagement what ends up happened is that
some of the videos that we put up the ones without notifications they don't do
as well obviously because they're not getting notified whoa that was crazy
Orianna powerful but it's it's compensated by more views on the videos
that we are putting up and then the idea the theory was if people are coming back
and watching these main videos that I'm highlighting then on the right side the
other videos will show up and people will click on those and then want to
watch those and so far it seems to be working it's early days so I was not
recommended as a strategy not that not that anybody else is really producing as
much content to be able to replicate the strategy like most people are even
producing one video a day so if you are if you're if if anybody's looking to
kind of copy it I would say any video you're putting up you want to obviously
be proud of but then put notifications on it's only for getting to the place
where you're doing multiple videos per day that it might be worth doing
something different so far so good I'm surprised but it was worth an experiment
the test I don't know if I want to answer any questions if I don't know who
the master is Justin all right good okay welcome aboard Jared broke the
secret there we go I like it thank you Justin great question oh okay all right
so the next question is coming from oh and just so you know we actually didn't
realize this that the last question that we answered previously is it he's in the
live chat today and so he's appreciative that you answered this question he says
thank you so much all right cool all right next question is coming from Chris
Chris says what do you do if you're not good at anything what do you do if
you're not good at anything all right so when I got this question you know I
really the automatic jump in response for someone like me who likes to
encourage is you know everybody's good at something and and you know just kind
of like be positive and encourage but for someone who feels like they're not
good at anything I'm kind of I would say you'd have to have gone through a lot of
different things to get to the point where you believe that you're not good
at anything and so I guess I want to kind of empathize with that a little bit
because if you're not if you feel like you're not good at anything then you
must have had a bunch of experiences where you felt like you just failed or
didn't you know didn't rise to the occasion in in that I think the best
steps to take if you're in that situation is not go about it from a
place of performance and what I mean by that is you guys have heard me kind of
talk a little bit and rant a little bit about education and how like you can go
into a school setting and leave feeling like you're you're you're not
intelligent because you just don't do well in that particular system and or
maybe you you know who knows what the reason can be so let's say you get bad
grades and you decide I'm not good at school or I'm not good at writing or I'm
not good at reading and it's not true you just whatever teacher or class
setting didn't work for the kind of person that you are instead of
approaching it from a performance level like what were the grades or how did I
perform at this task or that task I would take away the the measurement of
performance as your way of judging being good at something and think about what
do you love and what makes you come alive because I think if you take away
the pressure of oh if I'm not good at this or that and just focus on what am I
what do I love to do what makes me come alive I think it'll be a really good
step toward discovering where you're going to excel because we're all a
genius level talent at something how does that quote finish and then I don't
have been doing what you love comes with doing what you love okay we're all a
genius level talent and that's your quote Evan oh I don't know I say a lot
of stuff I like it okay well that's why I said it yeah Evan says it a lot we're
all a genius level talent at something but it comes with finding what you love
so right there I think the biggest issue to address is the mindset of anything
else and just understanding that they get good at something it's just a matter
of putting in work you had to have experienced that at some point in your
life right whether it's learning the skill learning the language you know
learning how to use YouTube learning you know how to use a fork like you had to
learn how to do a lot of stuff and it just comes with practice and so if you
want to get good at anything it's just going to come with practicing in that
awareness can hopefully help with some of the some of the self-doubt some of
the negative talk that's going on within your head because yes it's true you can
you you have to be good at something and you you can get good at something as
well just by putting in more work but for me it's just the more the mindset of
knowing that I could I could get great at anything if I just put in the work I
don't necessarily want to put in the work at a lot of things right just you
know it has to be something that fulfills me is it's aligned with my
mission of what I want to do and get better at but I could go out and get
pretty good at a lot of different things if I applied myself to and so adopting
that mindset I feel really helps and I think that's the biggest thing that's
holding our friend back here okay yeah yeah that's what I got okay any updates
it's a close game it's a close game I'm starting to get a little bit of
strength so I'm trying to push push down their base I might actually just get
tower this is pretty good come on go Teemo go go Teemo go Teemo gets
tower whoo yeah so game is going actually pretty decently I'm under
attack now but it's close it's close no no winners yet too soon to tell too soon
how you feeling Jay Jay is annoyed well that's not it that's not great he's
still playing well good I love it all right next question is coming from Archie
Archie Archie says where can I learn to improve my channel through better skills
I pay HP smart friend for malware general how to's and tips but they don't
help with this kind of thing much if at all like you want to improve it yeah it
sounds like it says he wants to improve his channel through better skills well I
think I know what heaven will say because we kind of just touched on it
in the last question you know you just you just you got to keep practicing
practicing really is how you get better I don't know if you're in a business too
that requires a certain level of you know some people have want to be really
professional on camera because maybe that's what their their business
requires but I don't know I even see on some of these really high level
businesses like their YouTube channels are just you know they're nothing fancy
you know so I think you can just just focus on making more videos and that's
kind of the best way to get better all right cool yeah I think I think the
quantity leads to the quality so you know practice practice practice will
help you get better I agree I think you I think you also need to learn what the
right thing to practice is so practicing the wrong thing will make you really
good at doing that wrong thing so you you know this is where modeling success
comes in this is where like when I was in my first business I was doing a ton
of work I was working hard I was I was doing my practice but I still wasn't
getting results and then by modeling success I started getting more results
too so just making sure that you're practicing the right things as well as
just flat-out practicing for me I look at I would look at who are some people
in your industry or what specific skills do you want to learn more of to be
better at Oh team is dying yeah what skills you want to get better at what do
you want to learn like you want to be a better speaker okay who's your favorite
speaker and what can you learn from them now are you gonna study Tony Robbins or
Les Brown you know I work with a media coach for a while to help me improve my
skills I found it super helpful important to the point where now I also
have my I have my people on my Toronto dance also team boom I just got a kill
pretty excited about that meet with this person once a month I have somebody meet
with her so that she can help them train as well and she helps people connect you
know and most people hire her use her for connecting in the media being a
better speaker but I I also want my team who teach salsa to go off and learn from
her as well and get better because it's still a skill of being able to connect
with people when you're at the front of a room so I think understanding what are
the skills that you want to learn that you need to get better at whether it's
technical editing skills there's channels just on that that you can learn
from whether it's speaking skills as channels just on that ideally there's
two ways of learning that I find helpful one is a lot harder than the other one
the one that's easy is when people lay it out for you when people say okay you
want to learn Photoshop here are the things that you need to do in Photoshop
you want to learn confidence here are the things that you need to do to be
confident where it's kind of laid out for you and there's a map the harder one
is learned by observation where you can look at an Elon Musk who will never tell
you how to be visionary or how to be confident or how to have faith in your
ideas he won't he won't spell that out for you and say here's how you do it but
you can learn by watching him if you pay attention and so there's a lot more of
that available if you can learn to figure out from watching and observation
skills what makes somebody good at what they're doing so it's just again
understanding the skills that you want to learn and then finding people who
have those skills modeling them learning from them and then putting in the
practice putting in the practice
that's what I got I'm under attack oh I died very sad all right so our next
question comes from Kara say this is hey Evan your videos are very resourceful
I'm learning a lot question can you patent an idea more like a program can
you patent an idea like a for a program if she says in parentheses more like a
program so she it sounds like she has an idea for a program she's wondering can
you patent program like a computer program that is not clear okay so I'd
say if it was not a computer program like if it was like a program as if
meaning a course or something on that line it would be difficult but that is
definitely a nuance of patenting that I'm not familiar with computer program
Evan would you you've seen anything like that you can you can patent you can pack
oh I'm gonna die I'm gonna die so hard it's it's hard to like the thing with
software patents is if you change a line of code then then you're screwed right
like somebody can copy you and do what they want to do and so a software
patent doesn't really mean anything the only reason to get a software patent is
if you are trying to get capital or get get bought out because sometimes
intellectual property there becomes important so to show that hey your code
is so valuable that that you know patents have been approved on it but
otherwise it's not really worth it and the best thing to do is just just keep
grinding just keep making it better just keep making new code if you have
speculation on it like you think it's worth doing that there's enough and you
are trying to get venture capital you you want to get bought out by a big
company then go talk to Pat Moyer and see your best bet so we got time for
more yeah great our next question comes from excuse me
Zaro and here is Zaro's question comment hi hi welcome hi back I love it
the friendly hi chinese are your friendly neighborhoods are just saying
hi I like it yep absolutely so two hundreds our next question and this
looks like it's a follow-up question from a previous message that she got
earlier she says I'm gonna think that was yet that was this week thanks for
applying to my message earlier from your advice I got some ideas sorry my
earlier message made you confused I'm kind of an introvert an introverted guy
often I am out of topics when I talk to new friends and strangers in various
situations I'm a bit scared while approaching someone don't know why I
need help and some tips on improving my self-confidence speaking killed speaking
skills fear of failure etc thanks for your time I like that I like it when
people come and then they get they come and they feel encouraged and kind of
start coming out of their shell and I I just think that I'm glad to Honda that
you got your your question answered and that you you know are encouraged by that
and that you're even sharing more about yourself so that's that's super cool so
fear of approaching someone self-confidence speaking skills fear of
failure lots of fears for sure and not uncommon for a lot of people to feel
that way one of the things that I've seen to hondra is I mean this doesn't
address maybe every single one of those fears but I've seen that when you
surround yourself with with people that value who you are just for you you tend
to the confidence comes because you're in and you're in an environment and
around people who value you regardless of your fears or flaws and and
inabilities and so I know that you've got a lot of different fears like
speaking skills and fear of failure and confidence I would start with just you
know trying to surround yourself with people who you feel confident and safe
around to be able to to grow in self-confidence I think that helps your
friends or your teachers or mentors people that really believe in you I
think that goes a very long way and it's a it's kind of like a practical first
step Evan what do you think the list was confidence and speaking skills and what
else yeah yep so he gets scared approaching people needs help improving
self-confidence speaking skills fear of failure so a lot of rap a lot of issues
of like self-esteem and how that so you know social maybe some social anxiety
that sort of thing yeah I think I think one just having awareness of it is a
great start I think awareness is the first step to solving any of the limiting
beliefs that you have so if you're aware that you're not confident if you're
aware that you're you feel like you lack in a certain area you are aware
that you're holding yourself back in some specific area for life I think
that's the first step to actually getting better so that's that's really
good I would say on top of of I think they had a similar kind of question
yesterday on top of reading the how-to's and you know watching the videos and
getting specific answers to questions I think to just if you if you want to
learn Japanese that the fastest way to do it is to go to Japan right yes you
can learn from the books and yes you can you know pay for Skype conversations or
you know whatever it is that you're gonna do but the fastest way to do it is
immersion is to go to Japan is to be surrounded by Japanese people and to
have you know almost no other choice so if you wanted to be more confident then
I would encourage you to create an environment that makes you feel
confident where you're watching videos of people who are confident not telling
you how to be confident but who are actually confident and embodying
confidence so as an example I was having a conversation with someone the other
day who has a small a small little thing on her face that she's kind of
upset about and she feels worried by and makes her self-conscious that she has
this thing on her face and it's not really a huge deal but she feels it's a
huge deal and she's always super self-conscious about it and so you can
say all you want like don't worry about it don't worry about it don't worry
about it but a thing that can really help her is to be surrounded by people
who have similar things and how they own it so you know Cindy Crawford who had
the mole on her face and she hated it at the start and then it became it became
her signature thing is how she became known and she's so glad that she didn't
get it removed like she wanted to at the start or you know people who have you
know a big gap in their in their teeth and like they own it right so watching
and being around those people and seeing how they deal with it deal with those
things can really help you I'm trying to find those people whose message you
really like and just being around it more often so I do it too like I I'm a
fan of Howard Schultz I love his stuff I love the way he he thinks and acts and
how he built Starbucks he doesn't really do he doesn't have a YouTube channel
right like if you want to follow Gary Vaynerchuk and get his thoughts he has a
YouTube channel you can follow him along and you can see what he's up to and you
like to follow him on his daily routine because he has he has a daily vlog too
right there aren't that many people that have that so you know Howard doesn't
have his own YouTube channel doesn't have a blog doesn't tweet like there's
no way to follow what he's doing so I put a YouTube search in news alert for
videos that lets me follow anytime Howard does a new interview and so I
learn from him every time there's a new interview that comes out and I just gain
a greater appreciation some more of how his thinking has evolved kind of rubs
off onto me and it's not that I thought that you need to copy and model
everything from somebody but it's something that I appreciate and how how
he does his work and so you know every every couple days there's a new video
for me to watch of a new interview that is done and every time I learn a little
bit more from it and I feel like it makes me a better leader I killed I
killed ash it's amazing so I think that's important and so you need to do
the thing that for you what you want to model what you want to learn go do that
and create that environment
well we're doing we're doing dragon I missed it sorry guys and it can know
that I think that can work for everybody I think I think most people only do the
how-to's and only do the the step-by-step and they massively disrespect the
importance that environment plays into all of this where you need to create
that environment to help you so if you want to learn Japanese go to Japan you
want to learn to be confident surround yourself with confidence and it'll seep
into you that's what I got
great
all right this game is the long game but we're getting some pressure we're
getting we're getting there we're getting there
we're almost we're in their base so it's good we've been doing some work team was
getting strong we'll see it's still tight it could go either way we just lost
two people on our team so who knows what's gonna happen
Toby okie-dokie next question is coming from this is sorry freezing up a little
bit here from but tool but tool tool is asking dear mr. Carmichael hope this
message finds you in the best of health I'm here to say that I have done
research in marketing it is like innovation in marketing innovation in
marketing I have been working on it for two years but I'm confused where to
publish it I've seen your videos and have realized that you might help me for
this issue hope you will consider that I need your help sincerely by my tool so
oh sorry I thought it was I thought Jay was saying something but no I don't know
he just made a crazy play now he made a crazy play he stole he stole something
from from the other guys so he did good job Jay he died for it but he made a
crazy play but I didn't want to interrupt hearing the question too is
that because it's a shit so he wants to publish something yeah and there's no
black and it's been marketing innovative marketing idea did we not do this
yesterday I feel like we did this one did we not yeah anyway I say okay we
didn't maybe I just read it or something okay yeah maybe you read it yeah I
haven't seen this question before okay perfect so in terms of publishing I'm
you know there's so many ways you could you could publish it I think it would
just depend on are you wanting to do online publishing is something that you
want to put in well book form so there's just so many ways that you could
publish are you wanting this to be available through you know YouTube
channel or a online you know business or again I think there's a lot of ways this
could go yeah so if it's a paper then you're looking at like who are the who
are the thought leader who's who's putting this stuff out there like any
scientist when they're doing their experiments and they come up with a
conclusion they want to get it published in a major paper or journal I think even
if you publish it on your own and you don't get it somebody made you to do it
and you probably know who the major people are writing in your industry I
think it's important that you do some promotion around it you have to get it
out there and let people know what you're doing oh I think we're gonna
lose we're gonna lose very sad very sad GG very sad it's a close game though we
almost we almost had it we had two of their we were in their base anyway let
me give a good let me give a GG here to these guys
GG well play oh yeah you got it you got to be active on promoting it too so like
I have a book with a major publisher penguin random house now that maybe
you're not reading a book but you need to do the work to get it out you need to
promote it you need to do interviews so that can be part of the potential
opportunity as well like the reason why I got a deal with penguin random house
was because of the audience that I have as a first-time author you know you
don't usually get deals with advances from publishers unless you have some
major audience and so if you're doing work to promote it think about the
influencers think about the youtubers think about the instagramers think about
the bloggers the journalists and reporters who cover this space and give
them a taste and let them know where they can find the full paper and that is
marketing that you can bring to the publisher whoever is going to be you
know creating this thing for you to say look all these people are interested in
doing it and that will hopefully help you get a better deal people are looking
for content if you had some amazing thing for entrepreneurs I'm interested I
want to learn more I'm curious to hear what you have to say and so there are
the me's in every industry where if you connect with those guys you'll be able
to have more success so I'm excited good luck
yes okay all right well I'm gonna I have to still eat and drink all this stuff
that's in front of me how how are we gonna wrap it up Rishi the Rishi like
we need that the Rishi ribbon it's so funny I call it something Rishi ribbon
hi a bow at the end I about the Rishi bow we'll figure it out as long as it's
a pink as long as it's a pink bow pink bow Rishi's pink bow okay what is
Rishi's Rishi wrap-up Rishi wrap-up it's not bad Rishi wrap-up always what you
got I love that oh my gosh yeah today there was you know I mean we got through
a lot of questions today and all coming from different places but it continues
to I think come down what I keep saying is it keeps coming down to how much
confidence is you know caught you have to deal with the confidence part because
you can have all these great ideas and want to do these great things but you
know when we're feeling scared and not confident it it can hinder us so feeling
it feeling it and make sure you are hanging around people that just you know
see your value see you worth and continue to believe all right I love it
okay Rishi wrap-up cool well thank you guys for watching have an awesome rest
of your Friday that's it for the live streams for us today we're gonna get to
work and do some amazing stuff here so you guys go out and crush whatever your
projects are today we hope that you continue to believe in yourselves and
cup and rise and whatever your one word is much love have a great weekend and
we'll see you soon